thank you
[Music]
okay speaking of
highly nightmare fueled deaths listen to
this just listen to this whole thing
okay so there's a pool party
in Israel like at a house
a bunch of people were there a bunch of
people in the pool everyone's having fun
a sinkhole opens up no under the pool
under the pool sucks all the water and
all the Inflatables animal Whirlpool
including party guests holy [ __ ] one guy
goes so deep into the sinkhole they find
his dead body at the end of a 49-foot
tunnel oh my god dude is he alive dead
dead body stand right just get sucked in
and you're suffocated everybody die no
just this one dude died but uh the other
people I believe got rescued but can you
imagine that just being in a pool party
goes and then everyone just goes through
that he's like being they're like being
flushed yeah you know oh that's [ __ ]
up I thought the inflatable is supposed
to keep you afloat though I know right
maybe the people
they got Goose Swan
see the people that were on it or if we
got it on video we got it on video you
shouldn't have been [ __ ] diving it's
right away though so once I hit play
that's right when this [ __ ] starts
what am I looking at oh my god oh what
hey get out of the pool though whoa
that she looks like a bathtub drain
that's a bathtub drain dude straight up
oh is there someone in already someone's
already I think we're stuck before the
video even started dude no one's even
trying to pull them out
dude a lot of these people look like
they're just kicking it dude it's like
it's like a shark attack you see a shark
attack your friends and your friends are
like help save I'm like nah player
because then I'm gonna die
when you're seeing that too like like
you don't you don't know what's
happening yeah that's part of like is
that part of the park like are they yeah
yeah yeah yeah
looked like they didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah especially that girl that's just
like chilling at the air just looking at
it they could be drinking or just like
registering some people were Sun Tanning
because you don't wanna you don't you
don't want that to kill your Vibe though
stay out there you're chilling you don't
want to have to save someone why are
y'all making so much noise yeah like
keep it down let's just help me stuff
come on great now the pool's ruined that
one guy in there when he was in there he
was probably the one being like come on
y'all because it's not that bad yeah
it's great down here
so yeah the um the crazy thing is these
people that own the home they got that
pool built without a permit oh that's
the reason why it was so shy that's why
you need permits that's why you need
permits man someone's going to prison
yeah yeah they actually were arrested I
believe the two homeowners
wow you guys know about like um you know
that all pools have a drain like
obviously this one's a little bit bigger
but you know they warn you don't like it
has to have proper safety yes if the
safety thing's off it'll it'll get
people stuck in there a lot of kids get
stuck oh [ __ ] and apparently like
because of the way I don't know where
they're situated a lot of people end up
sitting on it they get sucked in they
sit on it and it does wonders to your um
your butthole no way it'll just suck
everything out there no way would you be
sitting on it and then you're just your
face is
you just get awesome
don't worry guys I got it
the eyeballs go back it might be a rose
back in
that's great it might be a good idea
though next time I'm constipated I'ma
probably sit on there oh that'll do it
that'll do it man just don't do it to
your own pool oh that's true that's true
go to someone else's house yeah you know
like a gentleman a gentleman people do
forget like when they're in a pool or
just in a body of water that they just
think they're in water right but then
water technically has weight so if
there's something that is sucking down
here and if you're stuck there and then
now the water is in movement it's tons
on you oh yeah so it will keep you down
go with it they said you basically can't
get out once you're stuck in that drain
damn I'm gonna go dig first next time
then you're gonna go out go out with
style right isn't that like there's a
statistic that that [ __ ] happens like a
lot or something that people are like
putting their dick in the jet yeah of
like I think most boys that I grew up
you've never done it nah because I have
I've always had a phobia of just putting
my penis into really anything that's not
a human being really you know it was a
phobia yeah what's the what's the
opposite called because I had that you
try to put your dick in it
curiosity yeah curiosity
I had the Curiosity that's true if you
haven't [ __ ] all these different
objects as a as a youngin you haven't
really lived you call me approvers you
have to look forward to my like my
people going like my people's going out
like to like go to the grocery store and
my brother and sister want to go with my
mom I'm like yeah I'll stay just go
right the moment I hear the door closed
it's just like [ __ ] naked yeah I was
just getting naked I don't I just I
still do that yo I don't know what it
was I did that at a young age I didn't
even know what it meant I just knew I
just wanted to be just make it free
naked yeah bro when my wife's not home
I'm naked dog wait why I know I just
like being naked in my own privacy you
know what I mean why because I feel like
cause look it would just be weird if I
just walked around the house and she was
home and I was just naked all the time
all the time why is that weird see is it
to her yeah I don't think it's that sexy
I just think I think that's I think I
would freak her out I would perturb her
you don't think though like if you
walked around naked she'll just want to
like you know while she walks by you a
grab yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna Circle back and I'll
let you guys know yeah what happens and
if I get divorced
you've heard of free use right you've
heard of free use right can you can you
enlighten me a little bit so free use is
this uh concept uh where uh a woman is
like she'll be doing like from like
let's say a certain time period
she's free or like a day or two days
she's for you so her guy or whoever she
you know allows to do this will be able
to do anything sexual to her so it's
like a sexual game yeah I've got it and
then like so anything he wants he just
gets basically sexually right yeah so
you could be you could present to your
wife this way hey babe you you know I
could be your free use man news guy yeah
and I'll just walk around naked anytime
you feel the need the problem is is that
most of the time my wife is working from
home and she's like she's dealing with
like actual problems in like the grand
scheme of things that's even hotter yeah
that's that's crazy if I'm just like
walk around with my child literally be
her stress ball yeah yeah she said but
she's just over he's like a lot of my
wife bro that way she's on a call yo put
some [ __ ] clothes on man this is
crazy yeah and then come back with just
your white belt on
and I just walk it like this hey man
and the confidence too to be like Hey
listen uh every now that I'm gonna be
naked and when I am do whatever you want
yeah you know what though that's right
that's being a real man and I need to I
need to adopt this yeah that's a real
man yeah yeah you know I'm gonna be me
okay you're gonna get spanked bro this
is a very this is very empowering
until it turns on you until it turns on
you because in your mind you think oh
yeah free use yeah she's gonna [ __ ]
suck my dick and all this stuff but what
really happens is she'll come around and
Bone you in the butt yeah yeah she
[ __ ] spanks you and it makes you feel
very sub you know yeah and are you just
feeling like that's not what I was
thinking about man
you feel victimized that's not for you I
said for you it's not feel loose
that's exploitation
not my [ __ ] all loose thank you
and my asshole's loose imagine saying it
that way I'll be naked you can see me
around just put something in my ass
you're like no that's not what I wanted
that's such an unsexy thing to offer
your wife you might see my booty around
the house you know because she's like
yearning for it bro I don't want it you
want to put stuff in my ass I guess huh
when you forget a birthday present yeah
you just write a coupon out and say just
that put anything in my ass
I think she might go for that she she
has an obsession with like making me
like sweat a little yeah she likes to
make you squirm and [ __ ] right yeah she
likes to see me do this she likes to
mess with you oh that's perfect she
likes the mind games with me because I
remember you said that like you gotta
like hold her hand when she touches your
butt yeah she's like hey come here and
I'm like that's why I don't like she
goes hey come here oh and I'm like
I start walking over and she's like turn
around I'm like stop talking like that
bro oh so this is more of a this is more
of a power yeah it's a power Dynamic and
she's laying on the couch right she's
laying like a [ __ ] like a queen and
[ __ ] she's like come here [ __ ]
Cleopatra she pulls my hips over turn
around I'm like nah come on yo I'm just
like trying to go to my room yeah yeah
yeah wait what you need it my underwear
yes I'm in my underwear like what you
need to do is be one step ahead of her
right yeah she goes come here yeah you
go there and then right she has to poke
you in the butthole yeah you already
have a Sharpie right there a Sharpie yes
when she touches her box what the [ __ ]
what's all this ink oh
[ __ ] I already put some in them hey
you know that might be really funny yeah
you got like put a bunch of white out
yeah exactly and it's already it's
already in there stick it out like this
yeah yeah and it's just [ __ ] oozing
out whatever the phone
credit card just put one of those those
sets of those sets of chattering teeth
hey cool
wind it up real good dude she's like ah
[ __ ] and also but instead of a Sharpie
why not put melted chocolate oh it's a
good choice
Ghirardelli's in there he's a real troll
dude
and then it's just a snack yeah dude out
of my ass crack dude and then you can go
it's chocolate baby and it makes it hot
again do you have Tick Tock do you have
Tick Tock no I don't because they saw on
Tick Tock they do this thing like
husbands will do this thing we're like
hey
on an important call like she's on a
zoom meeting and then he'll go to her in
front of her and then he'll take his
clothes off I've done that before she
got mad because these women start
laughing
they're trying to hold it together while
they're doing the meeting oh yours got
mad she got mad she was on a very
important call though
[Music]